I'm sitting here with Jacques, one of our lead front end engineers.
Do you like tofu?
>> I do, well, well prepared tofu.
>> Well prepared?
What does that mean to you?
>> There's a whole spectrum of, of, sort of, the preparations of to, of tofu.
And, I-
>> What about like, a hunk of tofu from Costco or something?
>> Just a raw hunk of, of tofu.
>> Yeah.
>> Probably not the most delicious.
>> Okay.
Why?
>> It ha, it, there are so many things you could do with it that would
add additional flavors to your, to your tofu.
>> Okay, so there's a saying that I heard, well actually that I made it up.
It's called be tofu.
And to me it applies as well to code.
Do you have any idea what I'm talking about?
>> Not really.
>> All right, so here is what I mean by that, tofu to me is pretty bland,
it's fairly uninteresting, it doesn't really have a flavor of it's own.
It does, but not really, so if I get dropped into a code base.
What I want to do as a programmer is I want to be tofu.
I want to look around me and just absorb and
seep in the flavors around me, or the culture.
Right?
The way that the people wrote the code?
I want to write mine just like that for consistency.
If they use jQuery, I'm going to use jQuery.
If they're not using jQuery, I'm not going to use jQuery.
If they don't put semicolons, well,
I'll be really unhappy about it, but I won't do that too.
>> [LAUGH] >> note, always use semicolons.
>> Always >> Can you tell me an example of maybe of when that
may have happened to you?
>> Yeah >> When you dropped into a codebase and
it wasn't exactly the way you would have written it?
But-
>> Yeah, absolutely.
When I first joined Udacity, it was on launch weekend.
And there was already some code going, and once the code is rolling,
especially when you're trying to get stuff done on a deadline and there's not
really a, a good place to say hey, we might be able to do this better.
Sticking with that culture means that at least your code is consistent.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And what that means is that once you get the accent of the code down.
And you will from working in it.
You know, from, from experiencing it and, and coding around in it.
It's much easier to understand the code base as a whole.
That consistency is very important.
>> So, it's basically really important to have your one code base have
one single accent for consistency.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
Because when you start working with the code.
If you have to shift your mental model about how this is written,
every time you open up a file, or within a file, say.
>> Mm, from line to line?
>> It's really hard.
And so that's why having that, that consistency will at least let you,
once you know what the, sort of the local dialect is.
You, you can speak in that, you can write in that,
you can read in that consistently.
And you don't have to spend all of the overhead shifting your mental
model around about how this code is written, you know what this means.
>> So it seems like this is being polite to other coders that come along.
>> Yeah absolutely and to yourself.
>> To yourself?
>> It's going, future you is going to come back to this code and
go, why are there, why do half of these lines have semicolons?
>> So you want future you to not hate past you.
>> Yeah. >> Which is currently present you.
>> Exactly. >> [LAUGH]. >> And
that's like, a huge part of being a good engineer.
>> Mm. >> Is not getting future you angry at present you.
It's really hard, you don't always do it, but that's absolutely the goal.
>> Awesome.
So consistency within a code base even if it's not
necessarily your specific style, it's really important.
>> Absolutely. >> Awesome.
Thanks, Josh, for sitting down with me.
>> Definitely.
Remember kids, always use tabs.